present the next Awards an outstanding
actress was also the author of the book
Lauren Bacall buy myself a number one
best seller and with her an actor of
great range was an Oscar nominee again
tonight Miss Lauren Bacall and mr. Jon
Voight
good screenwriting is a very special art
it tells a story not only with words but
with images and situations and human
behavior actors are constantly searching
for the characters that are born when
those things come together and a good
screenplay that's why we're so pleased
to be giving these awards to the
screenwriters the artists who give
actors their characters the awards for
writing achievement are given in two
categories the first is for a screenplay
written directly for the screen and the
nominees in that category are autumn
Sonata story and screenplay by Ingmar
Bergman coming home story by Nancy Dowd
screenplay by Waldo salt and Robert C
Jones
The Deer Hunter story by Michael Cimino
Derek Washburn Lewis Gothika and Quinn K
roediger screenplay by Derek Washburn
interiors story and screenplay by Woody
Allen an unmarried woman story and
screenplay by Paul Mazursky
the winner is Nancy dad Waldo saw Robert
Ajanta home
I wrote my screenplay
in 1973 when our country was still at
war in Vietnam I was inspired by Vietnam
veterans and the women who loved him
they told me of the painful experiences
they had suffered in the name of
patriotism tonight six years later I
have an Oscar but for the people of whom
I wrote the war still goes on I'm
thinking of them tonight
thank you
I would like to thank particularly and
only not because of anything except that
I think they are the people who made the
picture some of the people that we talk
to some of the people who shared their
lives their war their post war their
pain their difficulties with us that
made the the heart of the screenplay
Bobby Muller and his fine wife bill
Haggerty Hager Ron Kovic
Roger Stephan's and his merrie Tim page
and so many others that I
I can't list I hope that they will
forgive me some of the people who would
prefer not to be named I believe who
worked in the veterans facilities here
in the Bronx and who shared their
experiences with us too all of the men
who fought in Vietnam those who lost
their lives those who lost their
innocence and those who working with
defoliants still don't know whether
they've lost their lives thank you
I would like to thank our extremely
talented director - be producer Jerome
Hillman and a really really amazing cast